how much would three hundred thousand
dollars change your life oh let's go we
deserve this meal right now how far
would you go for a chance to win it all
that really bothered me i felt bad
first of all
yeah
i got to talk to you today can we all
just like promise to not buy immunity
please because that's like a waste of
money they will share a pool of money to
survive we've all been
so good at lying and whatever they don't
spend kiera's got to go they take home
this is money game
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning good morning
to think that i thought um
pooing in the room would be a nor would
be like an okay thing
this morning and i was it was hell the
morning that i approached chance about
eliminating shane our logic was we're a
little bit older than the rest of the
participants and i deserve the money
because i played the game
probably going first
yeah yeah
i hope you're not mad at me if you see
this later on but kyra like
you gotta go
voting around
yeah
whenever rec comes up to me and chance
and says that we have a final three i
nod my head and then when he leaves i
make sure with chance that we aren't
voting wreck out and keeping kira
that really bothered me
when he was talking about getting her
out yeah i think he's very smart so i
feel like if we're gonna do
the
you know vote together i think we just
need to make sure that you and i are
protected so i think i have to make sure
that kira wants him out and then you
should make sure that he wants gear out
of
once
oh brushing teeth is a thing
i got to talk to you today
i can't i'll
so i know that rick
wants you out next
i think greg wants me out because he
sees me as a threat only because i am
charitable i get along with the other
guys and if i'm in it it means he has
less of a chance of winning okay i think
sam and i are on the same page
yeah for sure
and just want to do a dress thing i'm
gonna get her out okay because i was
down to like him
yeah yeah sam and i are both really
emotionally connected to kyra and her
story
so um that's not happening we're not
going to send kira home tonight
thank you for being honest oh absolutely
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i felt really bad yesterday
and still about voting her off and then
like now i'm like
he's like she was kind of a bit much
totally i was thinking about that this
morning i was like yo i feel like maybe
i tried to convince myself that it was
just me in reality she just was a lot
yeah it was right after the vote i felt
like [__] yeah yeah i felt bad it looked
like you had tears in your eyes that's
like just come i don't think i was ready
to cry but i think i was like i felt it
yeah i mean i felt bad too i am glad i'm
claiming it right now i'm glad i'm not
going back to that life
wow
no way there will be elimination today
you only get one vote and you must vote
immunity is available to purchase for 10
of the remaining plots
with the last elimination you could buy
a second vote
which you know that's great but buying
immunity the option of being able to
like save yourself essentially that's a
stronger temptation wow
can we all just like promise to not buy
immunity please because that's like a
waste of money like can we just like
promise that now yeah absolutely if i'm
being honest i don't trust rec anymore
after him
personally targeting shan and then now
targeting kira i'm not buying it yeah i
don't want it because because at that
point like if it goes to another boat
like we're gonna know who it is
kira's gotta go
if kira wanted to step up and become a
player it's just her time to buy
immunity how much do we have left right
now yeah ten percent 25 grand yeah that
would be 25k if anyone was the most
willing to blow 25 000 it would be
wrecked i didn't feel comfortable until
today
good [__] i don't think rick thinks he's
going home i definitely think he's going
to be blindsided by chance and sam
[Applause]
[Music]
oh let's go
the understanding between me chance sam
it's we go to the top three and we split
the money and in case we're forced to
eliminate one more person from that top
three
it would have to be sam
cheers yeah
[Music]
oh my god don't talk oh
you know rec has been showing his true
colors he's playing the game which is
really smart but um we see that he's
playing a game and there's more of us
and there aren't him so i haven't had
real beef in so long it tastes so good
wow
we deserve this meal right now
i might buy immunity
i don't want to and i don't think i have
to
but
if i feel it at the bottom of my balls
i feel it in my heart
i'm gonna buy the immunity
because i'm so close to winning
part of me that is worried that wreck
buys immunity and that would shake
everything up that would be extremely
awkward and kira would have to go
oh
okay okay no we got this okay all right
i'm gonna go take my stuff out of my
room
[Music]
kyra is kind of just a hanger on and
every time she opens her mouth it's like
a sob story i don't care at this point
this vote
is
too easy
i feel like i actually have an alliance
and it's sam and chance at the beginning
of this competition i felt really
hesitant of feeling like i could win
but as this game has progressed i do
think that i have a shot at winning
i really wanted
us to just split and go but
we never actually
tried the the uh the plan
and we've all been
so good at lying to [__] to kira
[Music]
so
you got a little world research power
but you got greedy
sorry man
[Music]
me and kira vote him
then chance vote himself that way if he
votes immunity and built somebody else
it would be a tiebreaker
oh [__]
why didn't i think of that
i trust everybody
and i think they trust me and i think
they should
i'm afraid he's gonna come in and punch
me
[Music]
i did not see this coming at all
i'm not gonna lie i'm a little upset
i'm a little upset
i just i thought after this hump the
game would really begin i got caught
slipping
feeling a lot of emotions right now
feeling a lot of betrayal
i guess you know they still saw me as a
threat and that's
that's smart of him
[Music]
at the end of the day i still got
outsmarted i got outplayed
that's the money game
come on out your goons
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
being gone um
there's less secrets now i felt like it
was really easy because he pretty much
thought he had the same deal with us
that you had with us so it's kind of
easy to be like kind of open about it
yeah it wasn't a hard lie it wasn't a
hard light i feel very good now that rec
is gone i feel nothing but relief and i
trust both chance and kira when they say
that they want to keep me and split the
money and at the moment no part of me
feels bad because he came to us first
this morning trying to back out on the
deal with you rec was the only person
that i really didn't connect with okay
now i think i you know i could say this
confidently we're trying it yeah we're
going for finals
seriously we're going forward too my
expectation is that we're still going to
do everything we can to keep
all three of us here let's be solid
though just in case they make us like
wake up in the morning not talk to each
other
you know what i mean we're going this
way right yes okay yes okay yeah the
game is supposed to see how far people
will go with money yeah and if we have
reached our limit yeah we went as far as
we're willing to go with them you know
we're gonna be just under 250
yeah
oh my god that's a lot of money i feel
like the mood now is incredibly hopeful
that we're all gonna walk away
with splitting the money splitting a
quarter of a million dollars three ways
is around like eighty thousand dollars
each it would take me forever to spend
i'll see you guys
hmm
[Music]
good morning
good morning i still believe in playing
a moral game
us staying in unity means we all want to
share the money at the end of the day he
really dug himself
his own grave right there because i was
down
yeah i was accepting 60k yeah
again like that would that would have
changed my life yeah alone
even though we've said it the last two
eliminations the days
were completely different it was like a
free-for-all would i take immunity or
would i um take uh i could cast an extra
vote so of course i looked at his
computer so i was like oh well i
wouldn't take community because i want
to take that money away from people i
was like i was like i understand like
the idea of casting an extra vote
because like that's less you know that's
like i'm rationalizing it allowed and
i'm like i should have been like no
neither one like i don't want to waste
the money and so i feel like any kind of
you know extra votes or
immunity that's just i i with these two
people i don't need to do that we're
fighting for just everyone to you know
go home with money
i don't think they're gonna morally
fight that right they would look bad
okay what was what did i say i was gonna
tell him oh
[Music]
oh
there will be an elimination today
okay you can buy an extra vote and you
and you can buy immunity
community costs 10 of the remaining pot
the ti if the tie breaker results in
another tie there would be a
random drawing to determine who was
eliminated
okay i have a proposition if you guys
want to hear it oh my god wait guys i
have a proposition i thought about this
in my head if immunity was offered
what if we all circled eliminate
immunity on our ballots
we would that would be 30k
i mean 38
but we would all be walking home with
money and we wouldn't be risking the
random draw
wow
if you don't want to be risky you would
do the equal ways if you want to be
risky
you would go with the tiebreaker and
just chance it i don't want to do that
like off the top of my head it's like
i'm i'm down to go all the way to the
random drawing because i don't want to
vote
either of you off
i i did not think that this game was
going to be as emotionally difficult as
it is with these with these eliminations
it would be one thing to
moving into this elimination
with a target but
i genuinely like both of these people
and i want them to have money i know
what i'm gonna do
and we might not all agree with it but i
don't think i can be swayed unless
there's a better alternative that
doesn't take money off i'm going to vote
to eliminate you
because i've had a final two a chance
since the beginning and if you guys
switch on that and if you switch on that
you want to keep her totally understand
if you buy immunity i completely
understand
but that's what i'm going to do
it kills me i'm going to do and i wanted
to tell you guys straight up when i'm
what's what's going to happen because i
respect you both so much
i feel like i feel like immunity extra
votes is just a waste of money and i
don't want to do that it's gonna happen
again
they have two more days to take more
money off the table
why did they have to make it like this i
know
i don't think you're being greedy i
don't think either of you guys yeah i
don't think you are either
[Music]
i think kira is a hundred percent going
to buy immunity the way she's speaking
and the way she's talking about going
into tomorrow it doesn't sound like
she's expecting to go home today
[Music]
because i made my commitment to sam
i want to honor that commitment
i also want to honor
your trust in me and what i mean by that
is
i'm also going to vote you out but i
love you
and i'm gonna make sure you know it okay
i appreciate you guys being honest
in three days we can see each other
again yeah right right this is just
we're not dying right it feels like
death it feels like it feels like death
yeah but we're not dying but we're not
dying
sam and chance both both vocalize to me
that they are voting me out so for me
right now my only option is to either a
go home
or be
by immunity
and send sam or chance home
if there was a final two situation and
you had the opportunity to split would
you
right split split and i know you would
too
i don't plan on telling them what i'm
going to do i think it would be best if
i just kept it to myself doesn't this
feel like the end to like all the movies
you watched when you're growing up yeah
like this is the end of breakfast club
right here yeah or like the fault in our
stars yeah
yeah i hope we're all cool
[Applause]
[Music]
i have my piece
thank you yeah
yeah i'll go home tonight i'm gonna go
watch scream and then
i'm gonna go rescue my portal beans fly
trap from the front porch
you're kidding me
all right you guys
here we go
all right can we have a group yep we're
hugging yeah we're hugging
[Music]
i'm gonna vote for kira because i
promised sam that it would be me and him
in the final two and if it's not
it's not gonna be my fault
this is
this is something
i feel like i know i'm gonna pick
but it doesn't make it easier
i don't feel good about it
[Music]
there will be an elimination today
you can buy an extra boat and you can
buy immunity an extra vote costs five
percent of the remaining pot to purchase
an extra vote write one extra mark on
the ballot
you can vote for the same person twice
immunity costs 10 of the remaining pot
don't do it
don't do it to purchase immunity circle
your own number
if there's a tie there will be a
tiebreaker you would not be able to
purchase an extra vote or immunity on
the tiebreaker
i said what i'm gonna do and i'm gonna
stick to it
if i willingly chose to go home i would
look foolish
[Music]
wait
if i vote myself
she uses immunity and votes chance
we send her home
oh my god wait
the concern is is what if she doesn't
immediately use immunity and she wants
me
chance is voting kira no matter what
if she uses immunity
invokes chance
if i vote myself we die
and then we will
around i might do it
if i vote myself i save chance no matter
what
i'm gonna vote me
chance ain't going home
chance is my boy he is not going home
but i lied to kyra
and it's a lie i'm accepting
we were all so sick and then left wait
what happened
it's crazy how this game works in a
blink of an eye
i'm voting me
i'm just trying to [__]
odds are low for this bite me in the
butt
oh
god
[Music]
you
i can't believe i'm doing this
[Music]
i feel like she's voting chance
and this will save him
[Music]
i know i'm doing the right thing
let's see if my gut and intuition are
right
morally i feel better about this
decision
god i didn't know i had this in me
jump i am
i wanted us all to walk out here with
money i swear
[Music]
this is a hundred thousand dollar
decision